The ceremony is--
Oh, no.
Lady Dodo,
how did you manage to do this?
You just couldn't stay away,
could you?
I was only gone
for five minutes,
and here you are injecting
yourself with poison.
- [mumbling]
- Dodo.
What are you telling me?
- What are you saying?
- No.
- What, you didn't do this?
Dodo, did somebody
do this to you?
- Oh, Lady Dodo.
- Mm-hmm.
Who did this to you?
Tell me who did--the wallpaper?
The wainscoting?
No? The settee?
The Rodin sculpture?
The Triceratops fossil?
The gold pelican vase?
The Zulu hunting spear?
The chair? The chair?
[gasps]
Chair.
Have you counted
the towels recently?
Chair gave it to me.
She's in the meat locker.
She did this.
What are you doing out here,
you muskrat?
The Commodore called out
the name Celine.
Sir, I'm the new servant girl,
Celine.
Chair!